new at 11 tonight with health awareness
month coming to an end the Vegas strong
resiliency Center shares ways to cope
with mental health issues arising from
mass shootings in fact the group held a
panel tonight that included a Survivor
from the one October shooting talking
about different strategies and dealing
with trauma while the Survivor did not
want to go on camera we did hear about
how she's doing
she is very inspirational and she
brought up a really good point that
living with trauma is hard it takes a
lot of work but I loved her point that
she wasn't going to choose to live in
fear she was going to take back her
power and she was going to choose to
live her life fully
the Vegas strong resiliency Center
encouraging anyone affected by the one
October tragedy or any serious crime in
our state to reach out for emotional and
mental health support you can find those
details on 8newsnow.com